sie alle wollen in den bundestag
deutschland deine grenzen
mit familien christa
guck mal an die piraten gibt es ja noch
ich bin positiv überrascht es gibt es
noch wir sind auch bereit mit allen
demokratischen parteien im bundestag
zusammen zu arbeiten sollten wir ein
gewählt werden natürlich das ist der
führungsanspruch sie stehen bei 0 5
prozent aber sie sind bereit mit allen
parteien im bundestag zu sprechen
ich bin jetzt am wahlstand von vault
wofür steht ihr denn wir sind eine junge
neuen partei die progressive inhalte
fordert und das in ganz europa und eben
vor allem auch zusammenarbeitet
so ich bin jetzt hier bei einer weiteren
kleinen partei hallo schön guten tag
können sie sich und ihre partei mal
vorstellen schön dass sie da sind all
unsere
partei ist lebendig und sie will vor
allem zukunft wie heißt die partei ist
die csu ja ja und wir sind ja ich bin
andreas scheid und delegierte stellen
klein parteien zur wahl vor die
schwierigkeiten haben über die fünf
prozent hürde zu kommen hat dieser nett
dass sie sich zeit nehmen armin laschet
kommt ja auch morgen sind sie dann noch
da ja ich bin morgen auch noch da ich
helf mit von der jungen union und morgen
wird natürlich ordentlich die
jubelschreie entlastet weil geheuchelt
jubelt jubelt
klatscht in die hände und schreit laut
seinen namen das wurde gesprochen vorher
nein das werden wir spontaner zu machen
ja eine csu unter fünf prozent kann man
das noch ernst nehmen das
selbstverständlich die werden wohl schon
zeigen wo der hammer hängt ja richtig
das ist noch die csu wie man sie kennt
der bilder erleichtert also sie stehen
hinter armin laschet
überall aber jetzt müssen sie nur noch
aufhören ihnen die ganze zeit messer in
den rücken zusammen die einzigen die
nicht kritisieren sind die medien das
sind diejenigen ja wegen jeder
kleinigkeit ja das stimmt aber die
medien senden ja auch immer nur ihre
orte wie sie gegen die laschen sticheln
also es ist auch schon zusammen sperber
wusste ich dann vielleicht in bayern
hätten ein halbes prozent mehr bekommen
wenn isch kandidiere
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir in den
nächsten wochen dokumentieren das ist
nicht nur darum geht sich mit
schlafwagen ins kanzleramt zu fahren auf
langsame geschwindigkeit wir sind der
unterhaltungssendung deswegen wäre es
gut für uns wenn sie einfach noch mal in
die kamera sagen dass ihr armin laschet
unterstützen ich unterstütze armin
laschet zu 100 prozent gut sie wissen
einfach wie man gute gags macht nochmal
direkten wahlaufruf in die kamera machen
ja wer für zukunft fortschritt und
innovation steht für sozialen
zusammenhalt der muss die csu in bayern
will er mir persönlich wäre einfach nur
wichtig dass die csu so abschmiert dass
sie nicht mehr den verkehrsminister
stellen ja ist das ein sinnbild für den
niedergang der csu lehre waren
angefangen
ja doch sie geben sich aber auch alles
schon am sonntag ja immer noch besser
als die linken
werden der ehrliche wahlspruch armin
laschet immer noch besser als die linken
jetzt
wieder ganz gut mal so
minijob bei ihnen zu bekommen weil wir
das ist total aufregend weil so konnten
sie ja keine einzige sendung bestreiten
also sie können gern mal bei uns ein
praktikum machen nicht oder nur das ist
nicht ohne aufsicht verteidigung ist sie
sind ja auch praktikant glaube ich gehe
ja war ich hab mich hochgearbeitet
wow hab ich noch ein abschiedsfoto mit
ja natürlich darf ja klar
natürlich
jetzt noch in meine kamera wunderbar
wunderbar
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da